le fait pour la fondation pour la
recherche sur la maladie de lou gehrig
vos premières impressions louis c'est
très très glacial mais en même temps
très plaisant j'hésite entre l'eau du
lac saint jean où le parc forillon
mais c'est pour la bonne cause ce qui
est important maintenant c'est de
relancer des gens pour qu'ils le fassent
pour la maladie la recherche la maladie
de lou gehrig alors moi allons vous
mettez au défi je mets au défi ariane
moffatt la chanteuse bien sûr et patrice
bernier joueurs de l'impact et pourquoi
pas
youpi tiens des marques bergeron hier à
faire son défi aller au pis alors moi je
mets au défi
l'équipe de la radio de radio-canada de
l'émission c'est pas trop tôt l'équipe
estivale parce que l'équipe régulière
reviendront la semaine prochaine donc
l'équipe estivale et jeu mais également
aux défis mon collègue jean philippe
wauthier et louis vous mettez au défi
qui une collègue d'ici musique rebecca
makonnen et je mets aussi au défi un
collègue à moi d'ottawa michel mathieu
nadeau le chef d'antenne du téléjournal
ottawa voilà c'est fait merci beaucoup
louis alors jean patrick on va se
diriger pour l'entrevue avec les gens de
là et c'est là alors qu on patauge dans
la classe en ce moment monsieur
villandry monsieur bérard qui sont les
maris ou à jour un goûter ont joué avec
moi ce défi du sceau de glace le ice
hockey challenge imagine bien ça fait
énormément de de publicité
pour votre pour votre corps aux en ce
moment voyez définitivement c'est comme
vous voyez c'est un événement qui est
virale sur les médias sociaux
donc la visibilité est créé et puis
comme vous l'avez fait c'est important
pour faire connaître la maladie maladie
de lou gehrig est une maladie qui est
connu mais pas tant que ça et puis c'est
important d'avoir cette visite des
activités lors pour lever des fonds
est ce que ça vous étonne l'ampleur du
mouvement mercredi dernier on n'avait
pas ça à pie xii pour un jour il joueurs
de la ligue nationale surtout qu'ils ont
peut-être donné naissance à un autre
niveau je pense est maintenant du plein
de gens qui font ça vous étonne ouais ça
nous étonne je pense aller on a jasé
ensemble puis c'est sûr que quand érudit
sidney crosby et puis plusieurs joueurs
de la ligue nationale et d'autres
personnalités qui ont participé ça comme
créer un effet d'entraînement mais je
pensais la force des médias sociaux
alain je pense qu au ci dessus soit la
même vie mais moi ce que je trouve
important en ce moment ici c'est que le
phénomène est intéressant oui mais il
faut aussi oublier la cause puis oui
c'est le fun qui nous ce qu'on aime
c'est que c'était on n'est pas ceci est
quelque chose de négatif demande année
la maladie de lou gehrig c'était le
suicide assisté ces choses là qu'on veut
c'est qu'on revive qui on veut démontrer
je fais mais qui est quand même la joie
de vivre chaque gens devraient profiter
de chaque moment de la vie qui du fond
on oublie son état santé moi j'étais à
100 watts et je faisais des marathons
puis on sera trois ans il m'a dit
complètement l'eau chamboulé puis
changer nous ce que je trouve le message
que maman c'est penser aux gens qui sont
atteints d'un conte faisceau du jour
nous qu'en vol de vélos oui c'était pour
passer pour que cette ampleur-là
irénique ma part j'aurais peut-être
sarwer qui elles toutes les jeunes qui
quittent le support mais apprennent
d'abord nous ce qu'on veut se fait
coller les mélodies sont fait que des
labels a dit rod être capable d'aller
chercher des enfants parce qu'on a
beaucoup de projets le professeur fait
quel genre de projet ce que vous savez
quoi
parce que les gens font des dons
d'ailleurs voyez probablement l'adresse
ou faire des dons on l'est on a mis ce
matin un site internet et celle à québec
à quoi va servir la france
tout voir et tout d'abord que je veux
aller va compléter d'abord la société
c'est l'autre québec la mission en
premières sont heureux c'est d'aider les
gens atteints les femmes et tous les
gens qui autour parce qu'un malien au
maillot n'est qu'en cette maladie là
nous touche mon frère aîné décédé
ça chamboule la vie des gens donc il
faut les supporter alors la société là
pour sûr première chose deuxième chose
la recherche faut mettre de l'argent
dans le back up comme on dirait pour
aller chercher vraiment des efforts pour
trouver une cure à cette maladie là ou à
tout le moins la ralentir éventuellement
après ça quand on a fait ça mais on a
d'autres projets plus à long terme
permet peut-être cependant à part d'un
petit peu oui
le sujet qui était qui ferait porter
c'est le rythme je dédie les et d'alizés
dans les personnes atteintes
sauvadet
mais si on navigue d'aubenas millions
qui était votre palette dallas au canada
cannes est décédé il ya des morceaux de
la maladie
c'était important pour vous nous suivez
reportage 400 watts et le développement
au bonheur
c'était important pour lui parce que
vous savez comment c'est difficile pour
cette année et il n'y avait pas vraiment
de doubler pas nécessairement mauvais
coup dans le stand à 100 parce que ce
qui est difficile aujourd'hui jcup notre
système de santé il faut vraiment faire
pour les gens comme vous et qu'on est
atteint de besoin de soins spéciaux vers
la fin la belle a dit si c'est dur pour
eux le site 24 heures sur 24
non aidants naturels sont complets et
plus alors nul parce qu'en ce moment il
faut y est passé reçu il ya peu dans la
source et qui sont disponibles non non
la seule ressource disponible cilicie
achats saljic
et malheureusement les sièges celle du
font leur possible on connaît aussi ce
qui se passe me voir dans l'épuré que
certains s'interrogent donc nous nous ce
qui est important alors c'est décidé de
développer un projet pour nous
développer
on a bien un comité et on est train de
plancher d'organiser je demande interne
et éventuellement avoir de telles
maisons 10,2 ce serait notre souhait le
plus rare mais ça coûte énormément dans
vous évaluez kong et à combien peut être
estimée n'en n'est pas rendu là c'est
plus dans un mode je pense de projection
mais comme on dit quand on a une vision
mais non
parce qu on a à 10 ans quand on est
supporter dans la satiété par d
dordain
la communauté qui nous a relancés
des choses qu'on veut
planifiez là pour
certaines je sais qu'il découvrait c'est
la partie
de plus
barguil depuis deux semaines pour
augmentation de 5 mille huit cent pour
cent ans des dons est ce qu'au niveau
québécois ou canadiens est ce que vous
le voyez ce que ses côtés elle alors
et ça mais nous on voit déjà des effets
bien sûr par contre par rapport aux
états unis on était comme une semaine
deux semaines et demie en temps sur la
vague parce que ça a commencé le 29
juillet à boston avec lui après que j'ai
commencé ça mais c'est sûr qu'on voit
déjà des effets on pense aussi à amener
des effets à long terme parce que moïse
au final la visibilité d'un gouvernant
sortent chaque année de maladies faire
connaître nos événements de levée de
fonds
on a entendu un seul autour de 12 13 14
septembre on allait marshall et c'est
peut-être le bel événement là au parc
maisonneuve
l excès c'est la grosse marche des
[ __ ] et d'air il ya toujours beaucoup
petit chat aux mille personnes qui
viennent marcher avec moi j'ai pas une
grosse marche devant moi je roulerai de
ce trou au km environ
c'est plus symbolique que d'autres
choses mais aussi on a les allures de
montréal avec nous
aussi la fondation tony proudfoot qui
existent au jo à ce niveau là allez
peut-être des morts entre et ça touche
tout le monde cette maladie l'appui
l'exemple donné on parle de tournai
propre qui est un joueur émérite avec
les alouettes
on a mal qui ronge aujourd'hui qu'ils
aient eu une carrière dans la ligue
canadienne de football qui convoie la
maladie alors ça touche aussi bien les
athlètes qui recrutent j'ai commencé
c'était un lanceur devait s band
gleeson ses blessures à cette approche
tout le monde dans la société
c'est vraiment une super merci beaucoup
merci d'avoir été avec nous ce matin en
espérant que ça donne envie aux gens
finalement de faut nécessairement faire
le défi du sur glace nous on comprend
que parfois ça peut être désagréable on
est vraiment bien placé pour le
comprendre mais en même temps de faire
un don c'est important donc vous allez
donc sur le site internet de tester la
québec alors que ça soit il ya julie
j'espère qu'il le prophète quand est ce
qu'on va préparer pour rien
voici les jeunes